[Music]
when I found you I saw raw untamed power
and beyond that something very special
[Music]
something beside me has always been
but I was awake that I need help
[Music]
I've seen this roster only once before
it scared me enough that
it doesn't know
[Music]
but the pastime
kill it
if you have to
that's the only way to become one you
met today
[Music]
[Applause]
we are the spark the fire
[Music]
this is not going to go
where you think
yesterday
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
hey everybody happy Star Wars night we
finally got a new trailer let's break
this down and there's a new round of the
giveaway it's actually for Star Wars
tickets because they're on sale now all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so you all probably picked up on the
theme of them hyping up how powerful Rey
and kylo Ren are just like this untapped
well of energy that Snoke is trying to
shape in kylo Ren die bring out the
special thing that he saw on him the
same way that Luke saw something special
in him I've only seen this power once
before then through all these training
scenes them in this area with the
Journal of the Wills or what about
calling the Journal of the Wills now it
could turn out to be something else but
it seems like that's what they're
pointing to she's trying to learn her
place Luke is scared and you see kylo
Ren reach his hand out in a separate
scene so obviously those scenes aren't
connected her saying I'm looking for
someone to show me my place and when he
reaches his hand out as if to offer it
to her you just freaked out a little bit
oh my god is everybody going sideways in
this movie because Luke is all about the
end of the Jedi Order but I think the
theme that they're trying to weave is
that they're trying to build a bridge
between each other they represent two
opposite sides of this at the beginning
of the movie she's training to become a
Jedi or whatever the New Jedi Order is
going to be called he's training to
become the ultimate force wielder this
Snoke is training him to be just with
albeit darker connotations but just
think about that idea about how they're
probably going to have to solve this big
galactic problem together I think that's
part of the thing like one won't have to
defeat the other even if they both don't
end up surviving the final film with
that completely rehashing Return of the
Jedi there's a measure of redemption but
kylo Ren actually kind of looks like he
tries to kill Leia during this movie
which I think would be fitting given
that he killed Han Solo he killed his
father he might as well be the one to
kill his mother too and in a separate
scene he says the best way to move
forward is to kill the past so that's
like right before he pushes his finger
on the trigger and you see Leia's
command ship so opening scene here just
kylo Ren surveying the hangar bay of
this Star Destroyer this planet here
with the gorilla walkers is actually
crate which we saw on the other trailer
we're just seeing it from the
first-order side and that's kind of the
way they cut the trailer too it's almost
like the last trailer was a Rey
trailer and this is more of a kylo Ren
trailer which makes sense the really
cool thing about these walkers though is
that you notice all this extra armor up
front here that's to prevent them from
being taken down like Luke did on Hoth
back during Empire Strikes Back
this scene here with the first order in
kylo Ren walking into this chamber looks
like it could either be controlled by
the first order but because of all these
red streaks in the rock here it looks
like it's connected to this a giant
crystal tunnel here these might be Kyber
crystals they might be something a
little bit different but it's just one
of the other planets in the film Snoke
actually does have a giant Star
Destroyer I think it's called the
supremacy it as you can imagine with a
name like that it's way larger than
Darth Vader Star Destroyer during the
original trilogy loved this scene with
her handing the lightsaber back to Luke
we finally see him take it and just look
at it like holy crap he doesn't even
know what to say he's speechless for a
minute and then you see her walking here
this still looks like rock to most of
the early part of the film feels like
it's gonna be there with her training
there's actually some pictures of her
just hanging out with the porgy when she
talks about the thing inside her finally
awakening she's talking about the first
movie the force awakened inside of her
and she's come to Luke to learn her
place but the funny thing that they've
talked about behind the scenes like Mark
Hamill's talked about this is that he
doesn't have a lot of answers for her
and she's actually kind of pissed off
she comes to him this legendary Jedi
that she's heard tales of her entire
life and he's so burnt out because of
what happened with kylo Ren like he says
I've never seen this potential before
and it didn't scare me then like it
should have but it does scare me now
so he's also worried about Rey going off
the rails the way the kylo Ren did
because I don't think that they've used
the term in the movie and they might
never use it I'd be happy if they did
it's called the chosen one remember they
use that during the prequels so he
thought that kylo Ren was the new chosen
one
so he put all of his time and energy
into training him it is a result of that
Snoke potentially gained the most
powerful Jedi force user in the galaxy
so I think part of the idea here is is
their training to achieve their full
potential unlock this thing that you
know both sides are trying to unlock in
each other they need to find new
teachings and they won't be able to
complete their training until they
confront each other but usually in the
way
at movies with opposing viewpoints like
this do they misdirect you by thinking
that one has to kill the other I don't
think that's the case
although kylo Ren seems convinced that
he has to kill his entire family which
would also include Luke Skywalker so I
know we're all crossing our fingers that
he survives to Episode nine and I
believe that he does but that's
unconfirmed that's just a rumor it also
kind of looks like kylo Ren is bucking a
little bit of his training too he
smashes his helmet so it sounds like he
might go the rest of the trilogy without
the helmet after this moment here did
anybody feel like they have deja vu for
the Anakin Skywalker scene at the
beginning of Revenge of the Sith when
kylo Ren was flying his special ship
here like weaving in and out of these
giant capital ships it feels like
they're trying to invoke a lot of that
so this might end up happening really
early in the movie because you see a lot
of their ships being blown up from the
inside
like you see Poe Dameron running for his
x-wing as everything is blowing up
around them just the way they cut this
scene with kylo Ren and his ship and
Leia like she senses what he's about to
do and just feels bad for him like I
think the whole thing with her is that
she just feels so much regret and
sadness over she's not afraid to die
she's almost died so many times in her
life that she's grown comfortable with
that it's just that she's so sad about
her family and what's happened with her
son
so as heavy is that is they balanced
that out a little bit with stuff like
the porks here I feel like that's
warranted because there's a lot of heavy
stuff happening in this film there's
very heavy dark side themes but how
about Finn versus phasma that's part of
his side mission like he gets to have
this whole other thing going on during
the movie Poe Dameron and Finn sort of
separate you have rey with Luke but then
gets to go on a special infiltration
mission with ROS who's one of the other
new characters so he gets a big-time
rematch with phasma and I don't know if
it's something that they didn't post
production or the way they're lighting
her suit but it just looks so much
better than it did during force awakens
and we finally get to see Snoke in the
flesh he says fulfill your destiny and
then you sort of see his robes in the
background is Ray has doubled over and
it seems like he's using the force
against her
so we'll actually get to see him do some
really cool stuff too but this does seem
like his throne room because you see the
Praetorian guards in the background here
so just more confirmation that we'll get
to see an act
to a confrontation between ray and Snoke
and is also sort of misleading when he
says fulfill your destiny I think that's
taken from a different scene and he's
talking to kylo Ren when he's saying
that so it's not like he's saying to Rey
fulfill your destiny but the way they
sort of cut the footage and he reaches
his hand out like he's reaching it out
to Ray makes it sound like she could go
either way like they want you to wonder
what she's going to do when she achieves
all this power like she has this path to
pick she's looking for her place as if
she's very suggestible Luke leader down
one path Snoke could also pull a kylo
Ren and seduce her to his side but let
me know in the comments what do you guys
think about this
I feel like this trailer is much better
than the last one and I do like some of
the story beats that they're teasing
here so what will happen is is I'll do a
follow-up video later this week just
leave all your requests in the comments
below there's so many things that we
have to talk about in this that it's
going to be the rest of the week before
we get through it all but there's a
whole bunch of stuff coming tomorrow to
a whole bunch of shows that are starting
so if you're big Blache fan that's
starting all the DC TV shows so be sure
to click that Bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss any of the videos but my
next Star Wars video will probably be in
a couple days but you can click here to
watch the other trailer and you can
click here to watch the Justice League
trailer from yesterday thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you